bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique la mission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation
resserrer les rangs derrière l'industrie
de défense européenne et bien c'est le
message envoyé par bruxelles et les
capitales européennes depuis la guerre
russe en ukraine reste à savoir comment
s'y prendre en achetant des armes
américaines ou en fabriquant soi même
ses propres armes pour en parler je
reçois charles beaudoin directeur
général du coges organisateurs du salon
de l'armement terrestre eurosatory qui a
lieu tous les deux ans en juin à paris
et jean-marc duquesne délégué général du
j4 le groupement des industries
françaises de défense et de sécurité
terrestre et aéro terrestre bonjour
messieurs bonjour jours un mot sur
eurosatory qui a lieu tous les deux ans
c'est quoi ce samedi il revient après
quatre ans de passer parce qu'elle est
un élan 2020 pour cause de pandémie
c'est le plus grand salon mondial de
défense et sécurité on me dit il
consiste à donner au gouvernement les
moyens à la fois de protéger population
dû prendre en compte l'environnement
vous vous disiez que c'était pas
seulement de l'armement non c'est pas
que l'armement loin s'en faut oui m
l'armement concédé 1 consiste à 10% en
fait des exploits du salon est dédié à
l'ensemble des moyens qui aujourd'hui
doivent permet de faire face à toutes
les menaces un qu'elles soient d'ordre
d'ordre terroriste aussi environnemental
on pourrait revenir sous les bienvenus
en les cas d'hier que nous vivons
aujourd'hui est là on trouve le monde
antique vient présenter ses produits
c'est ça absolument 62 pays
industrialisés qui ont dit une industrie
d'armement une industrie de sécurité
aussi viennent proposer leurs capacités
donc 1100 explosé à environ à sa
délégation de plus de 100 pays mais cent
mille visiteurs ils vont rentrer sur
salon prend et cinq jours vous disiez
que c'est la première fois depuis quatre
ans parce qu'il a été évidemment nul et
par la pandémie dont il doit y avoir des
nouveautés enfin qu'après une nouveauté
c'est que ce salon se situe dans la
bascule d'ordre mondial d'abord la
bascule on le connaît on le voit tous
c'est la guerre est étatique intérêts
tati qui revient à nos frontières mais
ça ne se résout pas à ça c'est la prise
en compte de plus en plus importante de
la protection de l'environnement et si
bien sûr aussi un numérique qui devient
la brique de base de tout de tout
système qu'ils soient civils ou
militaires qui explose avec des
potentialités très forte mais aussi des
fragilités très forte aussi bien la
cyberattaque pas aller aussi dan il est
souvent des capacités nombreuses faut
prendre en compte ces trois capacités
sur le salon alors que jean-marc
duquesne du j4 grosses potentialités du
secteur de la défense on a vu les
engagements des différents pays on a
plus de deux milliards deux cent mille
milliards d'engagement des pays en
europe on annonce plus de 200 milliards
nos gros potentialités pour ce secteur
c'est un secteur j'irai qui
effectivement en raison malheureusement
des circonstances et de des évolutions
géopolitiques
bénéficie actuellement d'une attention
particulière et d'un engagement d'aidé
et à ta secteur très particulier puisque
nos acheteurs sont les étangs et donc et
là aussi il faut là se préparer à voir
comment ce que nous européens nous nous
insérons dans ce dans ce jeu mondial et
je pense qu'il est important de voir que
une industrie de défense c'est un bien
commun pour chacun des pays qui en est
doté nous mêmes je dirais même dans le
cas de la france d'un trésor car c'est
le fruit d'une histoire histoire qui
remonte aux arsenaux de l'ancien régime
et qui avec les défauts l'effort
considérable qui a été fait après deux
dernières mondiale a permis d'affirmer à
la france sa seule dimension souveraine
en développement cette industrie de
défense qui couvrent un large spectre de
capacité et donc son salon normalement
on devrait voir des offres européenne
équivalent à les concurrents américains
russes chinois et c'est ce n'est
d'accord 73 % des exposants sont
européens d'accord avec les deux tiers
soit on paie 1 et plus du tiers sont
français alors pourquoi les européens
achètent beaucoup en dehors des pays de
l'union européenne c'est ce qui a pointé
récemment la commission européenne vous
êtes à fait raison les d'ailleurs nous
avons actuellement un sommet qui ces
rôles nous avons eu il ya un sommet
européen qui est du qui permet justement
de voir
d'affronter cette problématique pourquoi
comment nous européens nous pouvons
faire mieux actuellement et éviter que
nos investissements se fassent au profit
de pays tiers je pense à aux états unis
je pense à israël si on prend les
chiffres depuis 2008 de 2008 a
maintenant
60 % des achats d'équipements fait par
les pays européens ont été faits en
dehors de l'ordre c'est ça qui va à
l'inversé et les investissements
l'objectif de la commission c'est quand
même qui est des investissements communs
en collaboration à 35% dans les années
qui viennent alors qu'on est là 11% bien
sûr et mais c'est un vieux combat qui
est qui qui a démarré déjà avec l'agencé
européenne de défense qui il ya
maintenant une quinzaine d'années réussi
à identifier quels étaient les dl qu'ils
étaient les lacunes que c'était doublons
comme ce qu'on pouvait améliorer ça ça
malheureusement pas je dirais beaucoup
le progresser les circonstances
actuelles font que ce sujet revient sur
leur revient sur la sur la table de nous
permettre justement d'arriver à apporter
des solutions concrètes commune pour
résoudre ces problèmes et de lacunes que
nous avons on voit bien les lacunes dans
le lanthier rien et c'est à tous tout ce
que la guerre actuellement d'ukraine est
en train de révéler charles benoit c'est
un beau si vous l'avez dit ce sont plus
de 70 % des sondés européens à votre
salon mais à l'inversé inquiétant parce
qu'on se dit qu'il ya peut-être trop de
programmes trop de chars européen trois
véhicules blindés européen qu'il
faudrait un peu consolidé tout ça je
crois que l'europe vient de vient de
prendre conscience en fait que la guerre
revenait en europe et cette guerre a
toujours malheureusement lieu dans le
monde mais bien aux portes et d'europe
dans un dans un contexte guerres
interétatiques qu'on n'a pas vu ça
depuis 1945 donc effectivement l'europe
s'est aperçu que trente ans de ce que
j'appelle le confort opératif des lutte
contre le terrorisme ce qu'on appelle
les conflits asymétriques ou amenés à
utiliser plus certains moyens que
d'autres et qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouve confronté au besoin de
retrouver notamment une épaisseur à les
stocks de munitions de rechange qui sont
manquants en fait des armes et de se
réadapter à ce nouveau système et
l'europe se trouveront dans confronté à
ce tuyau l'ange certainement de pouvoir
d'avoir devant elle vingt ans parce que
les programmes d'armement c'est quelque
chose de terme c'est de l'investissement
long si l'europe s'y prend bien s'il
organise sa bdd d'ici 20 ans et pour
raconter la défense capacités je l'avais
d'indépendance peut-être que si à ce
moment les états unis regardent ailleurs
l'europe sera capable de complètement se
prendre en compte en défense alors
qu'elle repose aujourd'hui beaucoup sur
les états unis alors jean marc doussain
trop d'entreprises européennes ou pas il
faudra aller vers une consolidation
entre pays européens consolidation qui a
été fait en interne dans chacun des pays
alors ça a été fait différemment au
niveau européen il ya probablement une
consolidation un temps à mettre en
oeuvre on voit qu'on a besoin d'un
l'europe permet d'avoir un marché
intérieur comme on les américains
actuellement les américains ont un très
fort marché intérieur de par la
puissance je dirais de de leur budget ou
d'objets militaires à 800 milliards
d'euros c'est considérable
donc nous il nous faut là aussi je
dirais non rationaliser ce qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui est en cours et nous avons
un nombre d'initiatives qui sont tout à
fait intéressante regardons ce qui se
passe au temps avec nos amis belges eux
notamment le programme nous avons un
programme le nouveau programme
d'équipement des forces des forces
terrestres qui est auquel nos amis nous
amis belges participent et ça s'appelle
le programme camo capacité motorisés qui
est parfaitement emblématique de ce que
ce à quoi on peut arriver en europe à la
fois la dimension opérationnelle
l'interopérabilité opérationnel
mutualisation au niveau de hauts niveaux
gérer de de l'équipement de la
fabrication de la maintenance et c'est
donc là aussi un ensemble d'initiatives
en europe qui se font celle ci est
emblématique et c'est ce que nous devons
aller c'est un problème que les français
ne fabrique plus leur propre fusil dans
l'armée et que les français ne possède
plus leurs propres munitions en fait on
aurait pu entretient une capacité
s'attendent de fusil sans problème
d'abord ça vient du fait que l'armée a
diminué de moitié c'est quand même avec
90 mais nous sont revenus deux fois plus
de fusils d'assaut qui n'en fallait donc
l'état confronté à adé à des choix
budgétaires ceux des systèmes à
remplacer a fait le choix logique de ne
pas racheter des fusils d'assaut pour
alors qu'on avait pléthore de filiation
ce qui fait que industries d'armement
casse 30 ans en fer en filiation n'est
plus qu'à pas de le faire il ya un
abandon logique de la filière par
absence de demande étatique idéal pour
les munitions voilà il n'est pas une
mission en maintenant il faut comprendre
une chose aussi c'est que là la défense
de la france se fera dans un contexte
européen et je crois qu'il faut
maintenant l'admettre complètement et
deuxièmement là aussi il faut regarder
les budgets accordés l'état de l'accord
de un effort très important pour la
défense par rapport à d'autres
ministères et il a mis le paquet sur la
transition militaire mais on n'a pas les
moyens de tout développer donc faut-il
garder une industrie de fusils d'assaut
alors qu'il y en a plusieurs en europe
et notamment les belges en ont un qui ne
l'achète quand même pour 1 milliard 6 le
scorpion on peut imaginer qu'il peut
faire une réciprocité entre bénin notre
côté est ce qu'il faut sacrifier les
lignes de guidage domicile mais on est
quand même un des rares nations à
pouvoir concernant se complètent la
palette qu'une ceux qui ont des
filiations sert des filiations mais non
pas onze ans un porte avions nucléaire
n'ont pas franchement un chasseur aussi
plafond que jean-marc duquesne les
allemands qui annonce 100 milliards de
plus d'euros mais qui achète des f-35 et
qui achètent des hélicoptères lourds
américains c'est pas bon signe je pense
que d'abord il ya des mains une
dévolution allemande actuellement et
qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder qui est
qu'il faut saluer il ya je dirais un
lien très fort de l'allemagne ecstasy
nous le savons bien et est donc dans
tout ça il faut voir l'évolution
l'évolution elle se fait l'évolution je
dirais il faut voir maintenant au delà
des f-35 acheté par l'est les par les
allemands qui peuvent se considérer par
le biais de la
voir quelques comment les allemands vont
s'investir justement dans ce dans ce
projet on va le faire le char frankoual
ou par le char fabrice est en cours le
char franco-allemand pour mes envois
falun rappelé là on voit qu'on voit qu
actuellement il ya en fait il ya deux il
ya deux programmes emblématiques
il ya le programme du monde aéronautique
le scaf donc le système de combat aérien
du futur et puis vous avez dans le
domaine terrestre le mend round quand
pas de système qui aiderait le coup le
l'engin principal de combat de duthu du
domaine terrestre tout ça c'est des
horizons à 2035 tout ça on voit bien que
d'un côté sur la partie nautique le le
pilotage a été donné à la france sur la
partie terrestre a été donnée à
l'allemagne les discussions sont en
cours on prenait bien qu'ils arrivent
aussi à ses membres je dirais de
d'enjeux industriels importants et qui
nécessite de gier est de s'accorder au
départ car rien de pire qu'un programme
on s'accorde mal au départ il d'orissa
qui demande du temps merci beaucoup
monsieur pour vos réponses l'entretien
de l'intelligence économique est
terminée évidemment vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur france 24
points comme sur nos réseaux sociaux et
sur nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]